des rues bientôt revalorisé d'un gasser
et colis doré et docteur bretonneau font
partie du renouvellement urbain du val
fourré il est labellisé quartier
innovant et écologique par l'île de
france
si nous ne résolvons pas ces quartiers
si nous ne reconstruisons pas à ces
quartiers et bien c'est des êtres
humains qui vont vivre mal qu'ils vont
avoir des conditions de vie se dégrader
ici c'est 22 mille habitants sur ce
quartier qui au fond et plusieurs
quartiers c'est une ville et nous ne
pouvons pas accepter que vingt-deux
mille habitants soit dans une condition
de vie dégradées la signature a eu lieu
vendredi 9 juillet dernier un
financement à hauteur de 4 millions
d'euros le montant maximal possible
trois autres aménagements sont prévus il
concerne les mailles lopez et ronsard et
les abords de l'école rouge et bleu on
va avoir des nouvelles promenades à
l'intérieur du val fourré on va créer
des chemins pour qu'on puisse se
déplacer à pied en vélo en trottinette
les gens une demande de mobilité
différentes
et quand on a fait une réunion de
concertation il ya beaucoup de gens qui
nous ont dit même si le quartier du val
fourré ya beaucoup d' espaces verts mais
ils sont pas assez mis en valeur
ce label est un contrat de quatre ans
qui peut être prolongé de deux années
supplémentaires un projet de
renouvellement du quartier du val fourré
plus large à hauteur de 400 millions
d'euros est lancé